hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel as you can see uh my sun Baron
has really not faded at all after a week
and a half uh and my face is currently
the same shade of red as the Netflix
logo but uh today we're going to be
doing yet another systems design video
uh I recently acquired a copy of the
Alex zoo book which has given me some
more inspiration for problems ideas So
today we're going to be doing a payment
processing system for an e-commerce
website now uh I had always thought
about this problem and a lot of people
had asked me to make it before and I
always thought it was kind of dumb
because I was like well just go to
stripe but uh then you know I got some
inspiration and realize that the problem
is a little bit more complicated than
that so today we get to go through all
of those failure cases and talk about
them in depth okay so as previously
mentioned today we're going to be
building out the internal backend
payment system of an e-commerce site
like Amazon or Teemu or rakuen or
anything like that so the gist is you
know if I'm a user and I'm about to pay
for an item of carts we've got my
confirmation button over here we've got
some confirmation of which card I'm
about to pay with and then also an
itemized list of the items that I'm
paying and perhaps even the sellers that
that money should be routed
to cool so let's go ahead and formalize
some problem requirements so like I
mentioned this is forign e-commerce site
and two of the main things that we want
to do is number one we want to basically
account all of the payments for all of
our buyers and also all of the profits
for all of our Sellers and ideally those
should be ordered by time so that we can
quickly figure out over a given time
range how everyone is doing in terms of
how much they're spending and how much
they're making additionally it's very
very important that for an e-commerce
site like this we have a perfect record
of all orders and payments we do not
want to lose any of that data because
otherwise customers are going to get
very angry and that's when we get sued
so another thing besides not allowing
anyone to lose their data once they've
submitted an order is that we don't want
to allow duplicate orders as well if I'm
a user and I click the submit button and
then I click it again I shouldn't pay
twice the system should stop me from
doing that so no double submitting
payments AKA we want item potent
payments and then finally uh I'm not
actually going to talk about building
out the actual payment service itself uh
because the United States credit card
network is a complicated thing it's a
bunch of apis I don't want to talk about
dealing with bank accounts uh not only
because it would be boring but because I
don't know how to and if I did I would
be a wealthy man so uh we're going to
assume basically that for any payments
from the users to us Amazon the
middleman uh we can use something like
stripe and then uh for any batch
payments that we make to our vendors we
can use something like
depal cool so let's now go into some
overall design considerations I'm not
going to draw out any highle diagram
just yet but hopefully this could uh
maybe contextualize the problem for some
of you guys and give you some hints into
where we're going to take this thing so
number one is that we really don't care
about latency right I mean we do we want
to make it as good as possible but at
the end of the day we said we can't lose
data and so what that means is that even
if it takes a few seconds for a user to
submit their payment information that is
totally okay we care a lot more that
they're never going to lose that payment
information and so we're going to
optimize for that number two is that we
can't approve all payments instantly
right some credit cards may get flagged
as potential scam payment and so maybe
stripe is actually going to take a few
hours or maybe even a couple of days in
order to actually approve a given
payment and then send notice of that
back to us they might just say hey uh
for now this thing is pending uh and
you're going to have to deal with it
later number three is that as long as we
have one source of truth table right
with all of our pending payments and our
accepted or failed payments everything
else that we have can be derived off of
that right we basically need this one
Ledger or this one payments table and
then we can use deriv data that we've
used plenty on the channel before as we
all know I'm a flank a file and uh you
can basically ship all that data and all
those changes into Kafka and then make a
bunch of other databases that are
reading from Kafka and ultimately uh
making their own views on top of that
data so the first question is well if we
need to have one table that's
effectively perfect right no lost data
it has to be the source of truth how
would we actually go ahead and do that I
guess the thing that should pop up in
your head is using some form of
consensus right so we've got a a couple
of options one is just to use strong
consistency via synchronous replication
so let's imagine I have a leader
database over here and I have a follower
and then I have a
client what synchronous replication says
as we've covered many times in this
channel is a right is not considered uh
valid on the leader until it has reached
the follower the follower has
acknowledged it and then finally the
leader can return the status back to the
client so we have to go one two three
for the acknowledgement and then four
for the acknowledgement from the leader
back to the client now the problem with
something like this is that we have
absolutely no F tolerance whatsoever if
the leader goes down we can't make any
rights if the follower goes down we
still can't make any rights so that's
going to be a problem sure you could
perform failover on the leader but now
you don't have another replica to write
to and so as a result of that again no
fall tolerance synchronous replication
is not going to do it for us so now what
you might be thinking of is hm how have
we talked about achieving strong
consistency in the past while actually
having some ability to lose nodes or you
know achieve some fa tolerance and the
answer that we've at least spoken about
is using distributed consensus
algorithms so one that we've covered in
depth on this channel is raft but you
could also use something like paxos or
Zab any similar type of algorithm and so
the way that we would do that is on the
replication log so in the past we've
mentioned that these types of
distributed consensus algorithms are
used for multiple nodes to make sure
that they can basically write one type
of log and and then as long as one right
is committed in that log successfully by
the algorithm we know that it will never
be lost I mean it can be lost if I were
to go up to all three computers for
example and hit them with a hammer but
the point is uh it's very very unlikely
especially if we distribute where these
computers live and if we're only talking
about something like dis failures or
networking failures um so how's that
going to look well if you recall uh
basically to very very quickly sumarize
raft you have have some sort of leader
node you've got a couple of follower
nodes and basically in order for a right
to be committed it needs to First be
acknowledged by a quorum of nodes in
your cluster so if we have three that
means that the right has to go through
successfully on two of them and so for
that right to happen first our leader
gets the right it proposes it to all
followers and steps 2 a and 2 B this guy
is down over here so it's never going to
respond and then uh the top leader or
rather the top follower is going to
respond successfully so the leader says
okay go ahead and Commit This thing once
it gets an acknowledgement that the
right has been committed to the follower
and the right has been committed to
itself it can go ahead and tell the user
hey your right was successful now the
thing that you should note here is that
even though this is a great way of
ensuring that all of your rights are
going to be persisted to at least a
couple of nodes and that even if the
leader goes down that right will still
exist and continue to exist in
subsequent epochs uh the problem here is
that we are sending a lot of messages
over the network and so this type of
process is very slow if we expanded our
cluster size from three nodes to five
nodes again we have more fault tolerance
but even still our rights become slower
and slower so fortunately that's not our
main concern for this type of problem
but we will talk about how to make that
type of right a little bit faster later
in this video so the next piece of the
puzzle that I want to cover now that
we've talked about strong consistency a
little bit and how we can make sure that
all of our rights are persisted is
actually making payments item potent so
typically when we want to make something
item potent we basically have two
options one is to do something like a
two-phase commit right where I can say
well if you're the user uh and you're
trying to submit a payment uh you know
when you put it in the database uh
locally you also have to put it in
Stripes database and uh you know it's
got to work at the same time and if it
doesn't you're in trouble in reality
that's going to be a slow process and in
addition we can't just like go access
Stripes internals so we have to go along
with what ask us to provide which is an
item potency key so the item potency key
works because you know if we provide the
same item potency key for a transaction
twice stripe is going to take a look
back at us and say hey I've already seen
this one this is a duplicate payment I'm
going to ignore it cool so how will we
actually generate an item potency key
this is another piece of the video that
although I could go into it for plenty
of time I won't because it's effectively
the same thing that we did in our first
systems design problem on this channel
which is the tiny URL problem which
really means we basically have two
options one is that we can pre
materialize all of our item potency keys
right we create a bunch of random Keys
we split them out onto a bunch of
servers and then every single time
someone requests a new item potency key
uh the server is basically just going to
assign that request uh the next unused
item potency key so that's one option
another option is for all the clients
when they request an item potency key to
First basically generate some sort of
hash maybe it's based on the user ID
maybe it's based on the timestamp that
the request is being submitted because
ideally we do want as few collisions as
possible so something like a hash could
be nice and then basically it's going to
go to the database say hey I'm trying to
claim this item potency key and the
database assume assuming that we're
doing some sort of locking or maybe it's
a SQL database that's enforcing primary
key constraints is going to tell us
whether or not that key has been taken
if it has been taken maybe we bump that
up uh number up by one and try and take
the next key or something along those
lines so in that case we would probe for
the next available
now of course this is only going to work
if every single time that a client
generates a key if two clients generate
the same key their request needs to go
to the same database node uh so you know
we have to partition in a smart manner
uh that's partitioned by the the value
of the key itself or maybe a hash of the
key otherwise two requests could go to
separate database nodes and they might
not know about one another and then
they're both assigned the same item
potency key cool another thing that we
can do to make our table reads a little
bit faster is we can actually go ahead
and index that table based on that item
potency key because basically uh you
know we want a database full of item
potency Keys uh eventually we're going
to have to check whether a given item
potency key exists when we hear back
from stripe and so we want to basically
index our table by that key value so
that we can quickly find its
location so like I mentioned we have
this this one table uh this centralized
payments table or maybe we can call it a
ledger table or even an orders table but
the gist is we have one table that is
strongly consistent and so if all the
rights are going through it that
basically means they all need to be uh
ordered in one sort of distributed log
and that is going to be problematic and
hard to achieve so what would actually
be better is basically if we could
somehow increase both the right and read
throughput of our system and the way
that we might be able to do this is by
using partitioning right so basically uh
instead of just having one payment table
like this guy we can have a second one
and then each of them is effectively
running their own raft algorithm to make
sure that all of their rights are
strongly consistent now the nice thing
about this is this could get a little
complicated if we had to do any cross
partition rights then we would have to
introduce some two-phase commit into the
equation but the nice thing about
payment rights is that you know we're
just creating one row at a time and
we're just modifying one row at a time
so as a result basically all of these
rights are independent to one another so
in theory I would think that our
throughput would scale linearly with the
number of partitions we have so of
course we'll have to experiment with
that but it should should be a nice
solution so basically uh like I
mentioned what we want to do is probably
partition our nodes by the hash range of
the item potency key this way they're
distributed relatively evenly and also
again it means that if two users were to
attempt to claim the same item potency
key at once for their incoming
transaction or for what they're about to
submit to stripe they would both be
routed to the same database node uh
there would be a conflict and only one
of them would be able to claim that key
cool and then assuming uh we did the
Prem materialization strategy where it's
not clients generating their key but
it's actually the database generating it
what you could do is basically just
round robin requests from the load
balancer to try and evenly distribute
load across using one of those databases
so again that should help us to scale
out our throughput quite a
bit okay so let's now finally that we've
introduced kind of these opening
Concepts go over a pretty simple design
for how we're going to try and handle
all this payment information
so Step One is basically we have a
client over here and he finally lands on
that payment page he's selected which
products he wants and uh you know he's
just opened up the confirmation page the
second that we open up the confirmation
page we want to generate our item
potency key the reason being that you
know if I'm going to click the payment
button multiple times it's going to be
from that same confirmation page and so
I can't just generate the item potency
key uh when we click the button we have
to generate it uh like based on the
actual payment page load itself self and
then store that locally in the browser
so we create our pending payment the
second we land on this confirmation page
and get the item potency key how do we
do that well we go over here to our
payments
database so now what we might have is
something that says like key is 1 two 3
4 uh payment is
$10 and right now it's
pending cool so now in step two we take
our payment server and what we're going
to do is go to stripe with our item
potency
key now at some point in the future
stripe is going to do a bunch of stuff
and ideally it's going to get back to us
right we're eventually going to receive
some sort of notification from stripe
and we'll talk about that in a little
bit more with our item potency key
attached to it you can go look at the
stripe docs this is very much how it
works now our payment server receives
that we're going to go update the status
in the database hey this thing is no
longer pending now it's completed
and then using change data capture we
can basically sync all of this data to
our other databases and derive more data
from
it hopefully that makes sense as a
really high level overview however there
are a lot of systems involved here and
that means we can be prone to failures
so let's go ahead and talk about some of
those so for starters what I first
mentioned in the overview section was
that stripe does not process all
payments instantly so in step three over
here we're not necessarily going to get
get back this message instantaneously
from stripe after step two it could be
an hour it could be a day it could be a
week to process that payment so actually
what stripe does in their API is you can
basically give them uh a URL which is
known as a web hook so what a web hook
really does is you know uh I expose an
API from my server I tell stripe the
name of that API and then when stripe uh
completes a certain request for a
payment it'll actually go ahead and call
my API with the necessary information
that it exposes so stripe is going to
hit that on completion so this way even
if we don't receive word of whether a
payment was completed or failed
instantly our server always stays ready
to receive it great so what are the
failure scenarios now that uh we've kind
of explained how we're actually going to
hear back from stripe well for starters
number one what could happen is step one
goes through right we get our item
potency key we put something in the
database with the status of pending and
now after that maybe our payment server
dies and we never actually submit it to
stripe so that's failure scenario number
one failure scenario number two which is
also going to be a problem is that you
know because of the fact that you know
we submitted step two we said to stripe
hey uh go process this payment for us
and then stripe has some sort of web
hook saying hey we're going to reach out
to this particular payment server right
here some URL that it exposes however
maybe our payment server went down and
as a result now there's no web hook
that's actually exposed so we never hear
back from stripe so what can we do to
fix
these I think in my opinion the best
answer here is pretty naive and it's
just going to be polling so on some
infrequent interval basically we want to
look at all of those pending
transactions in our database anything
that hasn't yet been completed or failed
where we haven't heard back from stripe
and then we want to go ahead and ask
stripe hey what happened with this you
can still pull stripe for sure it has
API that allow you to do this so the
first thing to note is that a we should
probably only do this for pending
payments where some amount of time is
actually passed the reason being that uh
if we go to stripe and we say hey uh
what do you think of this payment has it
completed or failed and stripe says I've
never actually heard of this payment ID
or this item potency key then you're
going to say oh then you know what we
must have actually never made it to
stripe for this one let's go ahead and
delete it from our database however if
you do that after like half a second
from when you added it to the database
uh what could happen then is that you
know stripe just has yet to hear about
it it could be a slow network connection
and hasn't yet told us uh that the
payment is valid so you you may want to
wait some amount of time before you
actually start asking stripe about a
payment maybe 10 minutes maybe an hour
you could configure this in practice so
what do we do based on what stripe tells
us for starters let's say stripe says
Hey I've never heard of this payment I
don't recognize this item potency key
well that means that it probably never
reach stripe we should go ahead and
delete it from our payments table it's
not pending it just never even got there
in the first place number two is a
completed or failed status from stripe
uh then what we would want to do is go
back to the payments table and add the
completed or failed status seem simple
enough number three is stripe says hey
I'm still not sure yet we're still
processing this thing do nothing we'll
pull for it again maybe in another hour
that's totally fine so another question
is well okay we want to only do this for
pending payments where they've lasted uh
for some time right they've been pending
for maybe an hour already then we want
to start polling how do we quickly
figure out which payments these are
because like we mentioned uh right now
we're using uh a database that is
strongly consistent and as a result of
that raft algorithm uh rights are going
to be pretty expensive and in addition
if we want to make a good read from our
database we would have to grab some
locks on the data and now all of a
sudden we're interfering with rights so
what can we do instead well what I
propose doing is creating a pending
payments cache the reason being twofold
one we can store our data in memory
which is going to be faster than on disk
uh which is how it's going to be stored
in the database only a small percentage
of all the payments of all time will be
pending so I do think it's fairly
reasonable to assume that we can fit it
all in memory number two is that like I
mentioned when you want to make a
consistent read and you don't want to
read stale data um basically you would
have to lock on your database node to
get a good read otherwise uh you know
incoming rights could modify or mess
with the data that you're reading so you
don't want any contention there because
it's going to mess up the right
throughput of any incoming payments that
new customers are making so what we
would prefer to do is instead basically
isolate all of these things in a
separate cache uh so even though we are
going to have eventual consistency here
right we don't have maybe the most
up-to-date view of the payments uh we're
not going to mess with any locking and
we can read all these things from memory
and it's totally okay right like if I
see a payment marked is pending but it
really has been completed maybe I go to
the database and say hey I think this
thing is completed now the database is
just going to tell me yeah I already
know that doesn't matter so what does
this uh workflow kind of look like well
we've got our strongly consistent
payments SL orders table over here
because of change data capture
everything is going to be flowing
through Kafka and then we can just have
Flink as a cache where it builds up some
stateful cash of all the pending
payments and memory the reason I say to
use Flink is so that if it goes down we
can basically restore all that state
from a Snapchat uh sorry a snapshot that
we put in S3 and so the gist is what we
can do is as payments come in we can add
them to this linked list or rather a
doubly linked list ordered by their
timestamp and we can also have some sort
of hashmap pointing to those payments
the reason we want to doubly list link
lists with hashmaps is that removes from
this list are 0 of one if we hear from
stripe that a payment has been confirmed
and additions to this list are going to
be o of one and additionally the list is
already sorted by the incoming timestamp
so that way we can only poll uh for
payments that have you know existed for
a certain amount of time and we don't
have to sort the list or anything like
that it's just one single part of this
list is going to be you know beyond our
threshold and one is within our
threshold and we can just pull for those
item potency keys so like I said we're
going to pull stripe on some sort of
interval who knows if it's a minute who
knows if it's an hour you have to test
this out in practice and basically once
we hear back for any of those item
potency Keys we can go ahead and write
right back to the payment SL orders
database which again flows back through
CDC and into Flink so that we can update
our internal
State okay let's talk about derived data
a little bit more in general because
like I mentioned besides just having
this Ledger table we want to be able to
relatively quickly read certain details
about payments for both buyers and
sellers right so we want both the
revenue per seller in one place and also
it'd be good to have um either the
orders or basically just you know how
much a given buyer has spent in a given
time period as well so for this
typically what you want to do again is
use change data capture as long as this
guy over here is strongly consistent we
do know that eventually eventually is
the key word all of that information is
going to flow through CDC and into our
databases that we care about eventual
consistency is okay here because these
are just views for the user if they have
to wait another couple of minutes to see
their upto-date data that's okay we just
know that this guy is the source of
truth if we ever get audited or sued or
anything like that so basically you know
payments DB gets a change it goes
through Kafka it goes into some sort of
stream consumer and then the stream
consumer based on both the buyer ID and
the seller ID you know goes through a
load balancer and populates the correct
Shard of a database so for example if we
wanted to look at all of the cells or a
sales that a given seller has had over a
month and let's say that we see one
particular order where we've got seller
ID two just made $10 we consult the load
balancer see which node that goes to and
then write to the particular one now
because these are inherently all ordered
uh or rather because these are all
inherently um populated with a time
stamp right all of these
messages time 10 we can order them in
our time series database properly
and so as long as we order by that
timestamp uh now we can really easily
and quickly query the time series
database for the revenue of a given
person over a particular time
frame all righty so let's go ahead and
get into the diagram so as you can see
on the left we have our client so we're
going to go through the same exact
workflow that we already did from a high
Lev perspective but now ideally we are
going to just make it a little bit more
specific so as we mentioned step one is
that we have to basically ask our
payment service
for an item potency key the way that the
payment service does that is it can go
ahead and hit our payments DB over here
which is strongly
consistent payments DB strong
consistency that can act as a key
generation service we use round robin to
hit one of them let's say this guy in
particular apologies for The Accidental
flick and then we're going to come back
with our item potency key
we then use that in step two to go over
to stripe and give it our item potency
key in step three some amount of time
later our payment service should ideally
be hearing back from stripe and going to
the database to the appropriate one
based on the item potency key to either
confirm that the payment has gone
through or to say that it failed however
of course there's always a possibility
that this just went down and it never
went through in that case we want to
register change data capture onto our
payments database the reason being that
Flink over here can then see that there
is actually a payment uh pending payment
and so on some sort of polling interval
it can then go over to stripe say hey is
this guy actually confirmed or is it
failed once it finds out the answer to
that it can to go to the load balancer
to figure out the right place that that
item potency key lives and update the
status again this all flows back through
the change data capture for cka and back
into Flink so that it knows that it no
longer has to pull for that item potency
key the second second piece of this
puzzle is going to be doing all of our
derived data over here on the right we
also have a stream consumer pulling from
Kafka change data capture this doesn't
have to be stateful it just has to
basically forward messages over to our
derived database tables one of which
will be the user orders where we
basically sh it on the buyer ID and
order by the time stamp that it was
placed number two is going to be the
seller Revenue where we sh it on the
seller ID and yet again order by the
time stamp that it was placed finally
these should probably both be time
series databases
but I'm open to potential other
Solutions if someone said they wanted to
do something more column oriented uh
maybe put them into a snowflake or a
data warehouse or something like that
I'm open to that as well anyways guys I
hope you enjoyed this video and that it
was informative uh going to keep looking
for more inspiration for problems but if
you do have any feel free to jump in in
the comments section and ask me for
problems I do ask that when you give me
them please try and give detailed
functional requirements as well cuz a
lot of the times people will say
something and it's not instantly clear
to me what the exact challenge is so you
know really try and hone in on the
difficult part of the problem and that
way I can take a stab at it anyways
enjoy the rest of your week I will do
the same and I'll see you in the next
one